alright guys I want each one of you to
pick one person sitting here and tell
them what's the one thing you'd love to
focus on strengthening in your
relationship Kris Jenner is leading a
family therapy on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians and guys things get good
what we're gonna do is build the
communication Khloe is there somebody in
the bus that you would like to
strengthen with I feel like Kourtney and
I sometimes fizzle so I think I would
love to get us back on course and maybe
not be so reactive not for myself
yeah Kourtney is really at the center in
this whole conversation I don't know I'm
just like living life and whatever
happens happens
but back to this episode this whole
combo takes place on a bus in Wyoming I
want to fix you know my relationship
probably with Kourtney for those mean
reasons and those mean comments are you
saying that both yeah I mean I guess so
meaning even Kendall singles out court
in her own way I think sometimes there's
a lot of like judgment between all of us
yeah poor you say it a lot like they're
always like we can't be so judgmental
but you are too like we all have to
realize that we all are yeah but Chris
has her own way of making this a
positive and brings it all back to being
a group discussion sometimes I think
that people lash out at the people that
they love the most the love we have is
so unique and it's so special we have to
treat it like a little precious gift
from God baby now here's the interesting
thing all the sisters are there except
for Kylie but to be fair she has a lot
going on right now
[Music]
Scott Disick and Rob Kardashian are also
missing from the mix though we know
Rob's been around a lot more lately
how's he doing he's doing great you know
he definitely is more low-key than all
of us and we love that and respect that
he's been around a lot I'd say for the
past like a year or two
he's been around and we love having him
around doing good yeah he's doing really
good but back to the Kourtney of it all
it makes sense that they all want to
repair their relationships with her
she's been hinting she wants to take a
break from the show if the cameras go
away as long as they can come back
Kourtney you know they can go away for a
little bit but bring them back so we can
do another season or two and Kourtney
Khloe and Kim talked about it with et
too you mentioned that you might be
ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up with
the Kardashians where are you at on that
I'm just decided to spend more time as a
mom and you know put more of my energy
there and still but I'm not saying
goodbye right but I think you'll have to
see more of it on the new season season
18 just crazy isn't airing yet but it's
being filmed okay and currently do you
want in this room do you think the show
can continue going if you lose a sister
yeah I mean we definitely love Kourtney
and we will miss Courtney and whatever
she decides to do but people come people
go all the time this family we feel like
at the revolving door so Kourt you might
leave this week she'll be back they all
come back this is all a lot to unpack
but it's nice to see the family working
out their issues really yeah all right
guys that's it for today if you want to
keep Keeping Up with the Kardashians
make sure that you keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]